at least 95 people have been killed in
an attack in central Mali the latest
massacre in an ongoing conflict between
rival ethnic groups in the country it
happened in the village of so banku
which is inhabited by members of the
Dogon community officials said
identified gunmen attacked overnight on
Sunday virtually wiping out the entire
village fighting between Dogon hunters
and rival Fulani herders has already
left hundreds dead in the past year and
a half the aftermath of the massacre in
Saban KU dozens of bodies have already
been found among these burned and broken
buildings officials fear they'll find
more once a village home to hundreds of
people its population has been nearly
wiped out survivors say some fifty armed
men on motorbikes surrounded the town
after dark and attacked anyone who tried
to escape was killed the Malian
government has vowed to find and punish
those responsible the president offered
his condolences while traveling in
Geneva at this moment a thought for
those who once more have fallen in an
unjust cowardly and murderous attack in
the Dogon country no group has claimed
responsibility for the massacre but many
believe it could be a reprisal for a
brutal attack on the village of Ogas
augu some 160 Fulani villagers were
killed here in March by suspected Dogon
hunters the two groups have a long
history of disputes and fighting between
them has skyrocketed in recent years
the UN says it's trying to keep the
violence from spiraling out of control
the mission is coordinating its response
in support of Malayan authorities and
the United Nations system in Mali is
mobilizing to provide humanitarian
assistance to help people affected the
bloodshed has compounded an already dire
security situation in the country which
has seen an alarming rise in Islamist
violence in recent years
officials say militants with ties to
al-qaeda and the so-called Islamic state
are exploiting ethnic rivalries to boost
recruitment and expand their influence